- Hi everyone, welcome to the
daily Homeroom livestream.
Very excited about the
conversation we're about to have.
I will start with my standard announcement
to remind everyone that we are
a not-for-profit organization,
and we can only exist
with support from donors like yourself.
I do wanna give a special shout-out
to several corporations and partners
that have stepped up
in the last few weeks,
especially when they realized
we were running in a
deficit even before COVID,
and the deficit got
larger as we tried to have
higher server capacity and more programs.
So special thanks to Bank of America,
Google.org, AT&T, Fastly, and Novartis,
and just a reminder, we
continue to run at a deficit.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making
a donation to Khan Academy
so that we can serve many, many,
tens of millions of more
for a long time to come.
With that, I'm really excited.
Our next guest, Fareed Zakaria,
he is a well-known host
on CNN's GPS, a Washington
Post columnist, author,
and I would like to say, good
friend and mentor of myself.
And I think, first of all,
good to see you, Fareed.
If you can hear me.
- I can hear you, Sal.
It's a little bit jerky,
but I think we're all
getting used to life with
Zoom, which, I have to confess,
doesn't work as well as
the Khan Academy website.
(Sal laughs)
- I don't know if that's a
veiled compliment or not.
(Sal laughs)
- That is a compliment,
that is a compliment.
(Sal laughs)
- Well, thanks for joining,
and you know, when we
schedule these things,
there was already a lot
going on in the world,
and obviously, things are
just layering on top of it.
I would love to just get your raw take
of, one, how are things
going for you personally,
but what's your sense of
what the world is like?
You're in New York.
What do you think the
COVID layer is about?
economic layer is about?
And now what do you think
the kind of police brutality,
racial, systemic racism
layer is all about right now?
(Fareed laughs)
- Oh my God.
- Go.
(Sal laughs)
- That's a big ask, but
so let me try and do it.
It feels to me like at the very start,
it became clear to me,
and I wrote this the week
COVID kind of exploded,
that this was going to be a
series of cascading crises,
because we had never seen
anything quite like this,
because you first have the pandemic.
We realize, okay, we're in
a genuine global pandemic.
And you don't have a lot
of actual global pandemics.
SARS, MERS, these were regional.
They never spread.
So this is really the first
thing we have experienced,
where it really, I mean, I'm
sure you've noticed this, Sal,
when you call somebody
in India, Bangladesh,
you talk to somebody in Korea,
you talk to somebody in Europe,
they're all dealing with
exactly the same thing.
There's a strange sense
in which we're united around this disease.
Then you had the second
extraordinary thing,
which is historically
totally unprecedented,
which is we induced economic paralysis
in basically most of the
richest countries in the world.
75% of the global economy
went into a lockdown.
Nobody's ever done
anything like this before.
That's why the numbers we were seeing,
frankly, in terms of the speed and scale,
dwarfed even the Great Depression,
because even with the Great
Depression, it took years to get
to the unemployment numbers
that we got to within weeks.
So you've got that layer.
Then I think we are now going
through the third layer,
which is the widening
inequality of the response.
So the rich world is
able to deal with this,
because it can print money.
Rich countries can borrow, essentially,
in an unlimited fashion.
China, the United States, Germany.
The United States above all
really has the ability to print money,
because it has kind of sovereign
capacity like nobody else.
And so, while everyone's uneasy
about it, you can do a lot.
I mean, the United
States did in three weeks
what it did in '08, '09, in three years,
and it is probably going to do more.
But then you get to the part of the world
which can't do that, and you're
beginning to see that now,
with the India's, the Brazil's,
all these places where
the disease is spiraling,
they cannot lockdown any longer.
A large part of the economy is day labor,
which means people make
the money that day,
spend the money that day on food, right?
So you're dealing with that,
and then you add to it the protests,
which I think are not unrelated.
I mean, I think you've
got, in the United States,
40 million people
unemployed, nothing to do,
watching this brutality on television.
What does all this do?
It produces nervousness, anxiety,
a sense of purposelessness, despair,
and then against that you
have, in America's case,
the oldest story in America,
the greatest tragedy
in American history,
playing out one more time.
So I think that's the trajectory.
Now, personally, you asked.
I gotta confess, for me,
it hasn't been a big deal.
I'm lucky.
I have a large family.
So I've got three kids.
I've gotten to see my kids
more than I've been
able to for a long time.
My son is back from Yale.
My daughter's back from boarding school.
My little one is here.
I've got a job which I
can do reasonably well,
where I can get about 90%
of technological capacity
and 110% of intellectual capacity.
just because it's so
interesting and so engaging.
I've been working on a book.
That's easy to do from anywhere.
I miss real life, but I've
been able to cope just fine.
- And where do you see this going?
First of all, you did a great job
of being able to cover
all of those layers.
But where do you see this going?
I mean, there's really two
layers that you're talking about
that I think are really interesting.
One is that disparity between the rich
and the poor countries, and it seems like,
to your point, and I've
been studying this myself.
It seems like the US does have
almost this infinite
capacity to print money.
The federal government
can borrow the money
and distribute it, and it seems like,
we could talk about what
the implications are,
other countries can't.
And then separately, you
have people who are angry,
rightfully angry about what
they are seeing in the world,
and it still has not changed,
and there is probably
an economic aspect that
it could morph into.
I guess taking one at a time,
maybe the latter one first,
where do you see the protest evolving to?
Do you think it's going to be, you know,
"Hey, this is how you have
to reform police training,"
and this and that? Do you
think it's gonna stay to that?
Or do you think it's going
to expand into other things?
- Here's the dilemma.
I mean, this is, at some level,
the oldest story in American
history, which is the story
of the way in which blacks have
uniquely been treated badly
by the American system,
from the Constitution
into which they were written into slavery,
250 years working without
pay in the most brutal,
dehumanizing conditions,
their families broken up,
100 years of Jim Crow,
then mass incarceration.
But there's another
piece of it, as you said,
which is truly about
the police and the way
the police handle things,
and they've come together.
We have a police force
that frankly looks more
like an army in most cities.
It behaves more like
an army in most cities.
It's totally outside of
the black-white issue.
It's a problem.
So, I think the problem for
the United States is this:
you can marshal the anger and the movement
for something like this at
a national level very well.
Martin Luther King did
it totally brilliantly.
But he was asking, his
ask was a national ask,
the Civil Rights bill, fair housing.
The ask here is that
18,000 police departments,
you heard that right, there
are 18,000 police departments
in America, have to reform themselves
and create different rules
that allow for bad police
to be penalized; frankly, to recruit
a different kind of
policeman in many cases.
How are you gonna do that?
I don't quite understand, you know?
And part of the frustration here, I think,
has been that people have seen,
look, we've been hearing good stuff
from the natural leaders for a while now.
Every time something like this happens,
everybody agrees this is awful,
we need to do something
about it, but you have
that national unanimity
or agreement or consensus,
and somehow, it doesn't trickle down.
It doesn't translate into a
difference in the day-to-day,
lived experience of an
African-American, and this is why,
because most of that is
about local police chiefs,
local DAs, judges who are often elected.
So we need a different model
where you take this passion,
and instead of directing
it at Washington and Trump,
and God knows he deserves it,
but it's not gonna make
any difference, you know?
What you need to do is
at a very local level.
- And do you think that's
going to be effective?
Do you think it's going to happen?
Obviously, it could be on
the police reform dimension.
It could be on the general
criminal justice reform dimension,
or it could be at the systemic racism,
which is a much broader notion, dimension.
Do you think this time is
different, or will the frustration
just continue, and three years from now,
we're back to where we
were, where people are angry
'cause something like this happens again?
- I hope something happens,
but I think it's gonna be
hard in the short-term,
because to sustain this
kind of intensity of effort
at the local level requires
that people stay mobilized
at the local level, which
they have not tended to be.
So then you would need a push
from the federal government,
from, really, the president.
Clearly, Trump is not that president.
He's not gonna be the guy pushing this.
So maybe if you had a different president.
You need some process,
because the crowds go away.
The police unions stay,
you know what I mean?
The forces that are
obstacles are very powerful,
local entrenched forces.
The passion of the moment
cannot be maintained.
This is what King was brilliant about.
He figured out a way
to channel that passion
and to use it effectively
at strategic moments.
So what you need is something
like that at the local level,
and the problem is you need
18,000 of those movements.
- Yeah, yeah, and I would encourage
anyone watching on Facebook or YouTube,
please send in your comments.
Going into the economic layer,
there's a question from Facebook.
Shoeb Mohammad asks, "What
will the future look like
"in terms of from an
economic point of view?"
And then from Facebook, these
are related, Fred Edder asks,
"Do you believe universal
basic income would help?"
What are your thoughts there?
Will this be a minor?
It looks like the stock market
thinks that nothing happened.
(Sal laughs)
How do you think it's gonna play out?
- So, what the stock
market seems to suggest,
and look, the stock market
can also be right today
and then wrong tomorrow.
We've all experienced that.
But if there's a message here, it is,
don't fight the most powerful central bank
in the history of the world.
You cannot fight the Fed.
The Fed has said that
they might buy bonds.
They might back junk bonds.
They might buy stocks.
The Fed is basically saying,
"We have infinite capacity,
and we're willing to use it
"on essentially infinite assets.
"There is no asset that we regard
"as being off-limits for us."
In that circumstance, how
could an asset go down?
You have the floor
of the most powerful central
bank in the world saying,
"We're not gonna let this collapse."
Well, that's a wonderful
casino game to play,
which is heads, I win,
tails, the Fed loses,
and the Fed can't lose, so you're fine.
So, I don't know how long can
the Fed continue to do that.
I mean, in a way,
it's changing the rules
of capitalism, right?
There's a sense in which you wonder,
and you have lectures on this,
what does price discovery mean anymore?
In a system where you
say, "Yeah, you know,
"there are markets, the
prices rise and fall,
"but if things get too
bad, the Fed will step in."
So, you have this kind of floor,
if the Fed says, "We'll
protect the downside."
So that's like, a meta-meta question.
Short-term, there's no
question, the United States
comes out of this the
best of all the countries
in the world, because of the same reason
that it came out of the '08 crisis
the best of all the
countries in the world.
I mean, people forget.
We caused the financial crisis,
the global financial crisis.
It was the irresponsibility
of some combination of the private sector
and the public sector
in America that did it.
Who came out of it best?
Without any question, the United States.
Our banks are more dominant
in the world than they were before.
It's the most extraordinary thing.
The banks, which were
supposed to be the origin
of this problem, are now
more powerful globally
than they've ever been before.
America's five biggest banks
have a larger market share than anyone.
So, there's a long-run question of,
there's article in
Foreign Affairs that says,
"Can you have magic money forever?"
I don't know the question to that.
Nobody knows the question to that.
I remember when Japan crossed
the 75% debt to GDP ratio.
People said, this is it.
No country has ever
done anything like this.
We're in uncharted waters.
This is gonna cause
huge problems for Japan.
Japan is currently at
250% debt to GDP ratio.
So maybe it's something a small
number of countries can do.
I think the most important
thing to remember is,
India can't borrow like that.
Turkey can't borrow like that.
Brazil can't borrow like that.
They borrow in short-term
debt, in dollars,
which means they have to pay it back,
and if their currency depreciates,
they have to pay more.
So that's very tough.
So I think for the US, the
big part that I don't think
has been fully factored
in by the market is,
this is going to be a very
slow, halting recovery.
I mean, you're not gonna have a crash
and a collapse because of the Fed.
But the Fed can't force people to fly.
The Fed can't force people
to go to restaurants.
It can't force them to go to
movie theaters that are empty.
It can't force the NFL
to start holding games.
So all that spending is
not going to take place.
Now, the simplest
principle of economics is,
"My spending is your income."
So if spending is down,
how can the economy
be anything but at a much lower capacity?
China is finding that
the industrial production
is up to 90% of pre-crisis,
but consumption is not even up to 50%.
So the Chinese are now trying
to give free gift certificates,
I think two billion dollars of literally,
you know, imagine getting
coupons on the street,
which you can just spend at retail
as a way of inducing expenditure.
I wonder whether that's what
we will have to deal with.
'Cause we're not at the
universal basic income level.
That's kind of solving
a different problem,
which is technology and
automation, globalization,
making it so large numbers of people
don't have enough to do and
can't make enough money.
What we have right now
as a problem is we just
can't get people to spend
money, because what do they do?
They can't take a vacation.
They can't get on an airplane.
So how do you force that?
How do you force
expenditure into the system?
- Yeah, that's super helpful.
For those watching, I remember growing up,
I was always confused.
When people talk about
central banks print money,
where does the money go?
To just double click on that,
what Fareed's describing is,
especially the Federal
Reserve of the United States,
which is quasi-independent,
but really a governmental institution,
can essentially print money.
Where does it go?
It goes and buys assets.
Normally, it buys government debt,
so it's essentially lending
money to the federal government.
The more it does that, the
cost of the debt goes down.
But now it's buying almost everything,
(Sal laughs)
is what Fareed's saying.
So you can imagine, as the
cost of debt goes down,
then the federal government
can borrow more and more and more
and do these trillion
dollar at-a-time stimulus,
and at the same time, the Federal Reserve
can get more aggressive and
buy debt from companies,
maybe even one day think
about buying things
like equities and be
a floor to the market.
But you know, there's an
interesting question there.
Your point, maybe the Fed could engineer
so at least the market has a floor to it,
and certain parts of the
economy, the debt markets,
but that benefits, and I think we saw this
coming out of the financial
crisis, it benefits homeowners.
You can refinance, and
your mortgage goes down.
It benefits people who
have 401(k)'s and stock
and shareholders, but the
people I've just described
are the more well off already.
What happens to, I don't know
if it's universal basic income
or this gift certificate-type program.
What happens to the people who
are waiters and waitresses,
small restaurant owners,
Airbnbing their house on a small scale?
How do they live is not
an obvious question,
and not an obvious answer.
- Yeah, so that's the
broader, the bigger question.
Just one factoid which
I think would be helpful
for you to understand,
so everything you said,
of course, about the Fed is exactly right.
Now, keep in mind, because
of all of the factors
you are describing, the federal government
is currently borrowing at .8%.
So think about all you homeowners
who managed to refinance
heroically at 3.25 or 3.5.
The government is borrowing
at 0.8%, 10-year bonds.
So, at some level, it's very
sensible for it to be borrowing
the money, as long as it
spends it on useful things.
That's the part which I've always felt.
The government has borrowed a lot of money
in the past 10, 15 years
and spent it on tax cuts for the rich,
which is the most idiotic idea,
because it is not
fundamentally productive.
But what you're describing is the problem
that we already have, which
was this rising inequality.
And COVID is actually exacerbating it.
It's exacerbating it on three levels.
The gap between the richest countries
in the world and the poorest
is going to explain for
the reasons we described.
The gap between the biggest
companies of the world
and the small mom and
pop's is gonna expand,
because in this digital
world, what's happened
is we've had a flight to
digital, a flight to size,
a flight to security, all of
which mean Amazon gets bigger,
and the small mom and pop get smaller.
Google gets bigger.
All these big platforms
get bigger and bigger,
and even in the non-tech world,
you're gonna see that same thing happen.
The biggest companies
will be able to borrow
at much cheaper rates.
Then finally, for people.
The COVID divide is
kind of a class divide.
Who can work from home?
It's digital workers,
service workers, consultants,
people like you and me.
Who anything work from home?
It's people who work with their hands,
people who generally
have lower-paying jobs,
lower status in many ways, unfortunately.
I'm not saying it's the right thing,
but the reality is that
that divide, again, expands.
So how do you solve it?
Look, I tend to think
that a better solution
than universal basic income
is a massive expansion
of the many programs we have
that would achieve something very similar.
My favorite program of
the federal government
is the most difficult to explain,
and my theory is that's
why it doesn't do well,
because nobody understands it.
It's called the Earned Income Tax Credit,
and basically what it is
is the government says,
if you work, we are going to make sure
that you're never below the poverty line.
We're gonna pick an
arbitrary Number and say,
"You work?
"For whatever reason, the
private sector does not pay you
"enough to cross this
line, we will top it off."
The great thing about that
is that it incentivizes work,
it keeps the private sector alive,
it doesn't distort prices
the way that minimum
wages do have that effect.
You create a minimum wage,
and there is some job destruction,
because there are low-level entry jobs
that won't be available.
This does none of that.
It's more effective.
It's a program that, frankly,
Milton Friedman and
Bernie Sanders both like,
and yet, it's hard to expand.
It's sort of complicated.
It's easier to explain minimum wage.
So if you could take a program like that
and double or triple it in size,
if you could take food stamps,
if you could take Medicaid
and things like that,
I mean, I think the key
should be to make it
so that Americans are
confronting a changing world
with many, many different
forces buffeting them.
But they don't have to go into it naked.
They don't have to go into it unarmed.
They can have the security of healthcare.
They can have the security
of good nutritional programs.
They can have the security of retraining.
If you give them all that,
then they can handle a world like this.
But if you don't give them that,
then I think you make it very difficult.
And the problems with universal
basic income are obvious.
There's a question of whether
you de-incentivize work,
you destroy the market a lot.
A lot of what it does
I think doesn't address
one of the core problems
that we're gonna face
in the world going forward,
which is it's not just
that people need money.
They need something to do.
They need a calling.
They need the dignity of work.
They need the sense of
status that that gives you.
I think honestly, particularly
for men, a lot of men
derive their sense of worth
from things like that,
and women are more complex, I think,
because they've always had the reality
of being mothers and caretakers.
They frankly have a more sophisticated
understanding of internal worth,
which is a little more socially grounded.
Maybe it's a construct.
Maybe we should move away from it.
But the truth is that's where we are now.
And I think that you put two
or three million truck drivers
out of work because we've
got self-driving cars,
and just saying to them,
"Here's a handout,"
I don't think you've solved the problem.
- Yeah, that's a good point,
and I like the Earned Income Tax Credit.
I mean, I guess one way to
view it is just negative taxes.
Right now, you imagine the
first X dollars is not taxed,
and every increment above that,
from, say, 20 to 30,000 is taxed at 10%.
That first bracket is
essentially negative.
- At some level, the
government gives you money.
At some crossover level,
you start giving the government money.
- Exactly, exactly.
No, but I agree, it makes a lot of sense.
So, I mean, a lot of questions here.
Actually, I mean, you know, one of 'em,
Dan Companion on Facebook,
maybe we'll end with this,
"Is money just an abstract mechanism?"
I guess I'll change that into
a slightly different question.
He's asking about financial form,
what we should do post-COVID.
- Yes, the answer to
that of course is yes.
(Sal laughs)
- The answer on the money is yes.
But I guess one question,
we talked a lot about with
the Fed can do in the US.
What's the negative?
What's the potential limiter on it?
Inflation, is it something else?
And then just to finish
up, how do you think
the world's gonna be
in two or three years,
or how do you think it should be?
- Yeah, so the limiting
effect for a central bank
is usually, it takes two forms.
One is your currency
collapses, and second,
you've got the hyperinflation,
and the two are linked.
And the basic idea is simple,
which is if people think
you're managing your affairs
really irresponsibly,
if you have debts that
you clearly can't pay,
basically, people start
fleeing your currency.
Nobody wants to buy your government bonds
and things like that.
I think the US is far, far
away from that scenario.
The end of the day, the taxing potential
of the United States
government is enormous.
I mean, just to give one simple example,
the United States on average
has eight percent sales taxes, right?
Europe on average has 25% sales taxes.
So I'm not saying it's going to happen,
but what I'm saying is in extremis,
if the United States government
had to find a way to make money,
it's very easy to imagine
doubling the sales tax.
It's very easy to imagine moderate rises
in income tax for the middle class.
If you're talking about
huge amounts of money,
obviously for the wealthy,
you can do a wealth tax.
Again, I'm not saying
these things are all good.
But the United States
is not in a situation
where you would say to
yourself, "Oh my God,
"they've got these big budgets,
"and there's no way they
could ever pay this back."
That's just not where we are.
So I think, you know,
my feeling is the focus
should more be on what
are you spending it on.
If you're taking another
trillion dollars out,
it would be great to spend
it on infrastructure.
Frankly, that's all the
people you'd employ,
are exactly the kind of people
we've been talking about
who are having challenges,
people who work with their hands,
people without college degrees,
people who maybe don't work in big cities.
There's a huge double whammy here,
which is you help the
economy by creating greater
and more efficient
transportation and communication,
but you also help these people have
really interesting jobs
with dignity and such.
(Fareed laughs)
The small question of where we'll be
two or three years from now,
I think that, you know,
there's a part of me
that feels like it's easy to exaggerate
the degree to which there will be change.
After the influenza of 1918, after all,
don't forget, the next big
thing that happened in America
was called the Jazz Age, the Roaring 20s.
So people got back to restaurants.
In fact, they went back so fast
that even though you had
Prohibition in place,
alcohol was illegal, you
still had the Jazz Age,
and you still had the Roaring 20s.
So people obviously, you could even argue
they were desperate to congregate.
They were desperate to gather.
So I never bought the idea
that what you're gonna see
is a kind of replacement
of life with digital life.
I think you see some level of it,
but you're also going to see
enormous amount of social.
Aristotle said man is a
social and political animal,
and I think that's very true.
But I do think you're going
to see the acceleration
of a lot of these trends
that are already in place,
for the digitization of life.
I think that every big company,
WeWork may have failed, but every company
will become WeWork, by which I mean,
every company is going to say,
"Why do you need to come in
to the office nine to five?"
I remember in your book, you
talk about how the school
is an outgrowth of the
19th century factory model,
where everybody gets in one place,
you throw information at them,
they get through the conveyor belt.
By the time they're 18, they're out,
when with a modern
office it's very similar.
Why does everybody need
to be in the same place at the same time?
Why do they need to work the same hours?
Much more efficient
probably would be a system
where people come and go as they want.
There'd still be an office.
I think there's still enormous importance
of real-life meeting.
But some people come in three days a week,
some people come in two,
some people come in five.
It varies week to week.
Maybe you don't need a personal
space that is your desk.
That's a very inefficient
way to us assets,
if you think about it.
Why not have the WeWork formula,
where these are all shared,
they are used by everyone?
Maybe everyone has a
personal closet or locker
or something like that where
you keep some of your stuff.
When you're there, you use it.
Everything is up in the cloud anyway.
And if you do that, and you
reduce office demand by 25%,
that's a huge impact on
the way urban life changes.
So I think that's just one example.
I think those are the kind of changes
you're going to see
that are the most
important from daily life.
The biggest change that's gonna happen
that impacts the kind
of world we live in is,
are you going to see an
acceleration of nationalism,
and in particular, an acceleration
of the US-China conflict?
Because if you look forward
and say to yourself,
there are two possible models,
one where this pandemic,
which is global in nature,
brings us together to realize, you know,
"We kind of need a better WHO."
By that, we mean we need
one that's better resourced,
better staffed, and actually has the power
to tell countries, to push
back against countries,
which the WHO does not have,
whether it's against China or the US,
and those rules were written by the US,
because we don't want the WHO telling us,
"You're not doing a good
job on this or that."
Or do we go down the path of Cold War II,
where this whole thing becomes
really fundamentally about.
- Cold War II, I like that.
- And dominated by a geopolitical, right,
geopolitical, geo-economic,
geo-technological struggle
between the United
States/China, which will be
completely new, because it is
between the two biggest
economies in the world.
US in 1950 was 50% of global GDP.
The Soviet Union was 15.
- Wow.
- China and the US will
be pure competitors,
and that is a whole new world
and a very dangerous
world and a divided world.
So which one of those we live in,
I think, is the big question.
- Wow.
Well, Fareed, you've given
us a lot to talk about,
and hopefully you've enjoyed.
In your day job, I know you get
to write on a lot of layers,
but on TV, you're always
asking folks questions.
Even when I see you, I know
that there's a lot in your head
(Sal laughs)
that needs to come out.
I think for anyone who's watching this,
I think, has a new
appreciation for Fareed's depth
and breadth of knowledge in all things.
So, I learn something every time we chat.
So thank you so much,
Fareed, for joining us.
- Oh, it's my pleasure.
I'm a huge fan of Khan Academy.
I would only reiterate the point you made.
What you've done is really revolutionary.
It is a non-profit, and
anyone who's listening in
should realize that if you
think about bang for your buck,
if you think about how much of an impact
you can have on helping people,
if you believe that
education makes a difference,
this is the best way to scale it.
So when you're done with
this, donate some money.
I tell you what, I'll do the same,
so you guys have to follow me.
- No, Fareed's been very kind.
He's helped us over the years,
and Fareed, I definitely
view you as family.
I tell everyone, for those
who are not watching,
we once had to, our families,
we went to the same conference,
and both of us dragged
our whole families along.
So they put us in the same house together.
I woke up one morning, and
you were feeding Imran cereal.
So anyone who's fed my son cereal
in the morning I consider family.
So thank you so much, Fareed.
- Great pleasure, all best.
- Well, thanks, everyone, for joining.
Hopefully you enjoyed that conversation.
As I said, every time I talk to Fareed,
you can kind of talk about
anything and everything,
and he's got unusual depth and insight.
So hopefully you enjoyed that,
and I look forward to
seeing everyone tomorrow.
We're gonna have actually a
Khan Academy board member,
James Manyika, who's also the head
of the McKinsey Global Institute.
He's done a lot of work on the
future of work and learning,
obviously one of our board members,
and obviously we'll talk a lot
about what's going on
in the world generally.
So look forward to seeing all of y'all,
noon Pacific, three p.m. Eastern tomorrow.